hey guys it's Monday August 22nd I'm
Mary and you're watching GameSpot news
first up two new ps4 models are meant to
be shown in September but I think one of
those models got leaked over the weekend
Sony will be unveiling a new PlayStation
4 standard model in September alongside
a new upgraded ps4 according to a report
by The Wall Street Journal citing
sources familiar with the matter the
aport alleges that two new consoles will
be introduced in a bid to maintain
demand for the ps4 the timing lines up
with the PlayStation event Sony had
scheduled for September 7th
it also lines up with the fact that in
June this year Sony confirmed that it
was working on a more powerful version
of the ps4 codenamed neo Sony
Interactive Entertainment CEO Andrew
house revealed that the console will
feature improved graphics and support 4k
resolution House also confirmed that the
consoles intended to be sold alongside
the standard version of the ps4 at a
higher price shut up and get to that
other console you got it
Eurogamer reported that it visited the
home of a person who claimed will
purchase the console through Gumtree
which is like UK's Craigslist it looks
real they also made a video of the
console booting up it's been taken down
for legal reasons which I think we all
know what that means but they can't stop
us from showing numerous photos of the
system from neogaf as expected it's
noticeably smaller than the existing
model it features round corners and
PlayStation symbols at the bottom and
buttons there it is feast your eyes
photos have not been confirmed to be
real do you live in the Americas I got
some bad news for your wallet Sony's
PlayStation Plus subscription is
increasing the price sony has announced
that PlayStation Plus membership prices
will rise to $59.99 for 12 months and to
$24.99 for 3 months the price of the
monthly plan will remain at $9.99 but
who does the monthly plan the new
pricing will go into effect on September
22nd
if you want to read the announcement
it's on the PlayStation Blog we're an
old post about August's free PlayStation
Plus titles were updated with this
statement this marks the first time the
PS Plus membership prices will increase
in the US and Canada since the launch of
the service in 2000
10 the new pricing reflects the current
market conditions while enabling us to
continue providing exceptional value to
our customers as a member that's you you
will continue to enjoy the benefits and
features that enable shared experiences
such as online multiplayer
free games and exclusive discounts you
will also continue to get exclusive
benefits like online games save storage
and discounts across the PlayStation
digital services you might have missed
this before so I'm gonna remind you
Canadian you don't get out of this
either the prices of the PlayStation
Plus subscriptions are also increasing
in Canada the yearly price will be
$69.99 Canadian 3-month subscriptions
will cost $29.99 Canadian and the
monthly price will be 1199 Canadians
what about the other countries you might
be ok as of yet the European PlayStation
Blog haven't indicated any price
increase in Europe
this is probably because there was a
price hike in the UK in 2015 and in 2014
Sony raised the price in South Africa
Ukraine Russia Turkey and India so
hopefully you guys are safe for another
couple of years
enjoy your wallet remember when we
thought we were getting ps4 fallout 4
mods in June well it's it's August we're
my mods the says des has provided an
update on how far out for mods program
is coming along for ps4 and you might
not like it on Twitter Dell boys 6 God
asked what we were all thinking where
those mods the Fez de marketing
executive Pete Hines responded the mods
program for ps4 is currently under
evaluation presumably by Sony and so he
cannot provide a release date on August
1st Hines said something pretty similar
telling fans on Twitter that Bethesda is
working with Sony to release the fallout
4 mod program on ps4 the process is
still under evaluation as soon as we
learn more we will share news he said at
the time official mod support for
Fallout 4 was added to the PC version in
April following a brief beta the feature
came to Xbox one in May with the plan to
run a beta on ps4 and then introduce the
features for all users in June however
serious issues of the ps4 version
cropped up and the Fez de ultimately had
to delay the beta program on that
platform as Hines said in that tweet
there's
no ETA for when the mod program will be
available on ps4 that sucks
keep checking back with GameSpot so we
can tell you when you can enjoy mods and
that's all I have for you today your
regularly scheduled host Jess Mick
Donald will be back from Fiji tomorrow
so I'll see you guys again some other
time bye
you